How do you know that Matthew, Mark,
Luke, and John are not the ones who
wrote the NGO? Finish him. They Matthew,
Mark, Luke, and John. To me, to me, in
my understanding, in my understanding,
right? I
see this event
happening after the
crucifixion or the resurrection after
that all of these things takes place.
Uh-huh. They begin to write. So these
are probably Roman people who figured
out what has happened and they have now
probably think No, I'm not. I can
explain it to you. They have
You explain you explain it. Yeah. They
probably now by this point by this point
now they probably think they figured out
everything that's happened and therefore
they you know they they make this book
up. Got it. And they take like I said
here and there and then they start
putting their stuff in and they bring in
the concept of father, son, and the holy
spirit. Got bro. What exactly? I know
you guys you're missing the information
you see. But you gave me what
[Music]
it's
God. It's God.
Thank you. Yeah. Yeah. And um so how
long did it take you to think of this
type of what is the interview? What are
you thinking about? So I it it came with
conversations and conversations with
Muslims and they kept telling me excuse
me they kept telling me what the what
the angel is not like they keep saying
you don't have the angil you know what
you have is not it you know it's not
Matthew Mark Luke and John Jesus wasn't
walking around with Matthew Mark Luke
John and I'm like okay you guys know
what it's not so then what is it and it
it just you know started from there and
I would I would not get an answer so it
was it was interesting to me that Like
the Muslims had a lot of comments on
what the injil wasn't but could never
tell me okay what is it there you know
okay so that's what that's how it it
birthed okay so what is the inil if I
was to um think at this point right
revelation revelation from god that he
always sends revelation to the
messengers right so we know that we know
that many of the messengers
no good there has been many books even
before Abraham had books is had books
Noah probably had books ID probably had
books prophet Idris they all so these
are revelation right so we don't know
what the name of those books were right
but we just know they were revelation so
in terms of what the inil is it was the
revelation that Jesus came with or it
was sent upon him, right? So, it was
just a revelation. Would you? So, so I
wouldn't say it is the Bible. I wouldn't
say that. Okay. It never is the Bible.
Okay. Because there's a big difference.
Okay. Right. So, so let me ask you this
then cuz um this is where it it stems
from how the Quran talks about like the
jail is with the Christians. They have
it and stuff. Are you talking about 547?
A bunch of 547 um 7157.
Let's go through let's go through 547.
Okay. Right. So it mentions how they
they have the angel to judge by. Right.
So so so so this is what it's this is
what it reads. It's been let the people
of the gospel judge by what Allah has
revealed therein. So my question is to
all the Christians to you. Do you
believe Allah is the one who has no son
nor begs a son has actually sent the
injil down is the one that you're
holding your hand. Good question. No, I
don't. But but here but here's the
here's the here's the caveat. Hold on.
Let me answer in full once again. I got
to answer you in full. No, but but one
second. I know you have a point, but you
got to let me answer in full. Yeah, but
if you're going to try to answer that
now, that's like something that you're
going to try to bring into and just um
patch up your No, let me let me let me
tell you let me tell you my position.
First of all, one second. First of all,
we know first of all you you going to
let me respond? I will I will. But I
just want to be clear that we know that
Christian don't have the gospel. They in
that which Allah had sent. Meaning Allah
is telling these people to judge by the
gospel which Allah has said, but they
don't have that which Allah has said. So
we're clear on that. So he's going to
explain where that is now. Okay. So not
so I don't know what's happened to it.
Okay. We'll see. So Oh, good. He doesn't
know what happened to the in jail.
That's nice. Maybe when Jesus Maybe he
did. Maybe he did. So the reason why
whether I believe Allah revealed the
gospel or not, it it doesn't matter
because we're talking about what the
Quran says itself, right? So my opinion
or my personal belief about Allah has no
bearing on what the angel is or what the
Quran says the angel is. Okay? So the
the Quran is why you bring the Quran.
Let me let me just finish because we're
talking about the right. So so the Quran
said let me finish brother. Let me let
me finish please. Okay. I appreciate it.
The Quran talks about this in jail that
that Allah revealed as a revelation that
Jesus was going around preaching and
that the Christians had possession of in
the seventh century called the gospel.
So you're saying no. So they didn't they
didn't have this in jail in the seventh
century.
Christianity it wasn't even a religion
at this point. It was it calls them the
Christians. No no no no. They called
them the Christian because now it's now
it's moved down the
timeline. When it moves down the
timeline, you see this bit has moved
down the timeline definitely. Right?
This is at the time of the prophet.
Other warnings that Allah gives to the
people of the book, the Christians and
that that's again moved from the
timeline. Right? So who are the people
of the gospel? So so when we're talking
about when we're talking about the
people of the gospel, here's another
thing, right? Yeah. Who who are they?
Listen, the well well these are not the
people that came to the prophet's time
because the priest came to the prophet's
time. They had the Bible in their hand
and everything, right? They've had that
book and that's what they were
questioning about the um why are you
saying about our God that is not God's
not the son of God. He's a messenger.
They've had that debate. So, so you
agree that there was an
injil not in jail. Okay. So, what what's
the timeline of of verse 47? Is that in
time? No, this is in prophet time,
right? Okay. So, they did so they did
have the angel saying, "You got me this,
right?" And say this is like a Nokia.
Yeah. But I wanted a Samsung. Yeah. And
I said, "No, I don't want that. I want
the Samsung." When Allah makes this
reference, right? He knows what's in
their hand, right? But he's not
interested in that Bible. Right. Because
what is Bible? He says he confirms
what's in their hand. What is Bible?
Listen. What is Bible? Bible. Let me
just read. No, not about the Bible. I'm
talking I'm talking about this. This
right here. Yeah. But that's what the
Bible do, brother. Is is it the But I I
hear you. Is it the angel?
It's not the angel what they had in
their hand. What Allah is referring to
because look, you got gospel of mur.
Forget that for a second. I'm talking
about the angel only, right? In is the
gospel of Allah. I got you. So did they
have it? No. Okay. But all right. So
when it says, "Let the people of the
Injil judge by what Allah has revealed
in it." They don't have it to judge by.
No. No. So then why does Allah tell him
the reminder of what the true book was
to go back to that making a reference to
his revelation? All right. Just All
right. Just that revelation. Okay. Just
really quick. Can you go to 7157?
757. Anyone with water for me? Um I do.
I do. Fresh. I should have some in my
backpack. Um so everybody you guys got
my backpack here. Where's my wife? You
got my backpack. Can I get my water? Not
the one that they had in their hand. So
I'm not interested in that. I'm
interested in what I said. 7 7157 7157.
So basically the the brother says that
they didn't have the even when Allah
tells them to judge by the angel. So
Allah's telling them to judge by
something they don't have. And if they
don't, they're losers. Now I would look
up and be like,
"Allah, how could I get in trouble when
you're telling me to judge by something
I don't got?
I shouldn't I shouldn't be wrong, right?
Allah,
I'm going to go to hell if I don't judge
by something I don't have. That don't
make sense. All right. So, 7157, what
does it say? I know what it says. I
know. I know what you say. Okay. I want
to just um like lot of Christians here,
I've asked them this question like the
Bible that you read. Thank you for the
water. Of course. The Bible that you
read, just give me a second. Yeah. Bible
that you read. Um, forget the Bible
right now. Once again, once again, most
most of people think it's what Jesus
came with. Like the Quran we say word
for word is from Allah here it is like
people think well yet the Bible is from
Jesus but in actual fact right in actual
fact but we're just I just want to know
what this in jail is man you said I
didn't have the Bible is a collection of
books that originated from variety of
sources yesil is one of them including
oral tradition so including oral
tradition that could be the saying of
the harin and everything else the
followers of true Jesus the disciples.
Right. Right. Written records. Written
records and the work of different
religious community. What does that
mean? Work of different religious
community. Who are the ones that make
this Bible? You go and find these third
people. For instance, I think they're
Romans. Brother, this has nothing to do
with the topic. No, no, no. But I'm just
telling you what the Bible is. Thank you
for So, so, so that's not the deal.
Okay. So in the injil here it says in
7157 it says that they have the angel
with them right. You didn't open that.
Oh yeah yeah it say it says they have
the angel with them. Correct. One
second.
[Music]
I'm keeping that.
Thank you. You're welcome. You'll be
rewarded for that. I appreciate it. Find
that everything gets rewarded. So 157 is
reading this people. I know you might
have had different people interpreting
this differently. No interpretation just
we just okay just read those who follow
the apostle the unlettered prophet
meaning prophet Muhammad right whom they
find mentioned in their own scripture in
the Torah and the gospel. Right. So they
have the Torah and gospel. Right. Right.
So so these are talking about the people
from the people who had the gospel. So
they have it. No, no, no, no, no, no,
no, no. It says they have it. No, no,
no, no, no. It said those who followed
the apostle. So those who had those,
they followed the apostle. Got it.
Right. Do you follow the apostle? I I
don't. But but but in here we He said I
could find them in in the in the jail
though. Right. So I have the angil to
find them in. Right. No, you don't have
the Okay. Do they have it? They had it.
Yeah. Oh, good. Okay. So they have the
in Muhammad's time. They have the
gospel. No. No. Right. This is talking
about Okay, fine. But remember they said
those who followed the apostles, these
one who have this messenger in their
books. Yeah. They saw it clearly and
they accepted Muhammad as a prophet.
Accepted him as a prophet. Very good.
Right. That's what he's talking about.
Good. So, but you haven't accepted that.
You're right. I I'm one of those who
haven't accepted it yet. You got the
Bible and the gospel. There's the
difference. Okay. Cool. That's the
difference. All right. I got it. That's
the difference. So, okay. So, according
to this, they had the NGO, right? They
have the gospel in Muhammad's time.
You're saying the Bible is not it. Fine.
I got you. It's not it. It's not
Matthew, Mark, Luke, or John. Okay. So,
they have this written book that's
called the Gospel, right? They had Okay.
Who wrote it? Well, again, it's probably
I'm not sure in terms of
um if you're talking about the children
of Israel, right? They had the book
before you. They had the Quran. They had
the book before us, right? We know how
that was written. I don't know about the
gospel. What I can say is how did all of
this come about and the Christianity and
the name it comes afterwards because DA
doesn't come with a religion that's
called Christianity. He doesn't come
with that. But you may find stuff like
that in the book. But how did it end up
in that book? Part of what the prophet
is saying when he's talking to the
people, when he's addressing the people,
you can see that this is how messengers
always spoken, right? So, so you don't
so you don't know who wrote it. Now
then, then then then when the people
wanted to bring in the father, the son,
and the holy this concept into it, they
use these things like we're just talking
about the NGO, brother. That's it.
Simple. Simple. No, but in Jill in Jill
is not the Bible. I got you. You already
said that. So when I asked you who wrote
the cuz it says they wrote it. It's
written and it's with them. Yeah. But I
wouldn't able to tell you that because I
haven't I haven't researched. Fair
enough. That's okay. Fair enough. Okay.
So you don't know who wrote the NGO. Got
it. Was it written during the time of
Jesus after his time? You don't know.
Okay. I got you. So we don't know when
the was written. We don't know who wrote
the NG. You don't know. Well, I'm about
to ask you. It's not about my I came to
the knowledgeable brother. I came to the
Muslim. All right.
Yes. To the Muslim. All right. So then
here's my question. All right.
To me,
when you don't know who wrote the Yeah.
When you don't know when it was written,
how do you know that Matthew, Mark,
Luke, and John are not the ones who
wrote the Inil? They Matthew, Mark,
Luke, and John. To me, to me, in my
understanding, in my understanding,
right, I
see this event
happening after the crucifixion
or the resurrection. After that, all of
these things takes place. Uh-huh. They
begin to write. So these are probably
Roman people who figured out what has
happened and they have now probably
think No, I'm not. I can explain it to
you. They have You wait, man. You
explain it. Yeah. Yeah. They probably
now by this point by this point now they
probably think they figured out
everything that's happened and therefore
they, you know, they they make this book
up. Got it. And they take, like I said,
here and there and then they start
putting their stuff in and they bring in
the concept of father, son, the holy
spirit. Got so um Okay, let me wait.
Wait, wait. Thank you. I appreciate it.
Uh that was very that was very detailed
and explained. So as as far as the um
No, no, no. Let me let me explain it.
Let me explain. Wait,
bro. What? Exactly. I know you guys
you're missing the information, you see.
But you gave me what,
bro? I really tried, but that's
it. You can laugh what you got.
All right. They came after. Okay. Okay.
They wrote the book. All right. So, they
wrote the book after the resurrection.
Right. Now, remember, this is why this
is important. Think about it with me. If
Matthew, Mark, Luke, and John wrote the
gospel after the resurrection of Jesus.
Well, whatever they wrote, they wrote
the Bible. Okay. They named the Bible.
But but they called it Bible. The reason
when I when I asked, well, they do.
Gospel of Jesus. They do. No, they
don't. They call Bible. Literally, Mark
literally says, Mark 1:1, he said, let
me give it to you. Okay. He says, "This
is the gospel of Jesus Christ, the son
of God." That's what he says. That's how
he starts it off. Okay? So, so, okay.
After what? After the resurrection,
right? After what? Just after some time.
Whose resurrection though? Jesus's. No.
Yeah. Okay. Whatever. All right. We
won't get into that. I don't want to get
into it. You're right. You're right. I
don't want to know who resurrection.
I'll get you. I'll get you. Talk about
resurrection. Wait. No. No. Hold on.
Focus on the You going to get me on
that, man. Okay. But I want to confirm.
You're going to get me on that. The
resurrection is not Jesus Christ. All
right. We got it. The resurrection. We
got it. We got it. We got it. Guys, my
brothers, my brothers, my brothers,
please do not interrupt. Please do not
interrupt. He'll use you as a
distraction. Do not interrupt. Please
don't interrupt, my brothers. If y'all
love me and respect me, don't interrupt.
Okay? So, look, they wrote after the
resurrection according to what you're
saying. But here's the point. You don't
know when the angel was written in the
first place. The angel could have been
written after the quote unquote
resurrection or this ascension event
when Allah took him up. The angel could
have been written after. You don't know.
So, I ask you again, that doesn't mark
off Matthew, Mark, Luke, and John
writing the angel. Angel is not the
Bible though. So, okay. Are we talking
about the Bible? Well, we're talking
about the engine. My question is, have
you got the angel today? Well, look,
have you got the Well, you're saying I
don't. Have you got it? Yes, hold up.
We're getting there. Trust me, we're
getting there. So, you want to get But
when I buy something, you want to laugh.
No, I let you laugh, brother. I let you
spice it up. No, I let you spice it up.
You don't know when the angel was
written. Is your dish on the dish? You
don't know who wrote it. Yes, it's on
the dish. Yeah. You don't know who wrote
the angel. You don't know when it was
written. No. So, Matthew, Mark, Luke,
and John writing the gospel after the
ascension of Jesus doesn't disqualify
them as authors of the jail. Whatever.
So, how do you know that Matthew, Mark,
Luke, and John did not write the Injil?
Look, I don't know what they wrote. I
know they wrote the Bible. How do you
know it's not the Injil? Because I know
it's not the injil is from Allah. How do
you know they didn't write it? Right. So
what they they wrote everything and when
Allah is clear about the message in all
throughout all time through all of his
prophets through all of his book that
he's one he doesn't have a partner he
doesn't have a son all of a sudden now
he's changing his oh you know what this
is a good point he's saying how I know
is because if we base it off the
previous prophets and God's consistent
message if this what Matthew, Mark,
Luke, John doesn't match the consistent
message we know it's not the gospel,
it's not from God. So, we can judge
based off the previous prophets. So, for
example, if the previous prophets taught
that, for example, God is the father or
that God has a son and things of this
nature, then we can know that Matthew
and Mark and Luke and John are authentic
and according to God, right? Okay. Very
good. So, so for example, cuz I like
what you did then, man. That's that's my
cup of tea. That's good. But you're
going to let me come into this point as
well. Of course. Of course. Going to go
Isaiah. Well, no, not Isaiah. Isaiah.
Well, that's that's a good reference.
I'm going to go to Deuteronomy. I'm
going to give you a few. So, look. So,
here we got we got Deuteronomy 32:6.
Moses says that God is our father who
created us. So, Moses in the Torah
acknowledges that God is our father. We
don't. Well, I know you don't. And
that's hold one second. So, if you
scripture, why can I talk my scripture?
We'll go in a second. You're missing the
point. If you want to test scriptures,
which one is the authentic one? We can
change the goal post. I think that you I
think you just forgot the criteria you
gave. You just forgot it. Your goalpost
was I know that Matthew, Mark, you said
I I know that Matthew, Mark, Luke, and
John did not write the because it
doesn't match with the consistent
message of the prophets. So if we look
at what the prophets taught, we can
judge what is the angil or not. So if
the prophets taught that God is our
father and the angel, Matthew, Mark,
Luke, and John teaches that God is our
father, then we know that they wrote
authentic scripture, right? Can I answer
that? Yes. Okay. If a scripture has not
been tempered with, get this. If a
scripture has not been tempered with,
does God need to send another scripture
down to those same people?
If if a if a scripture on this earth
that's not been tempered by people, not
been changed by the people, does he need
to send another book? What was the
reason for the injil coming down? As
soon as it came down, everything in the
Old Testament doesn't like um you know,
it's not relevant anymore. Is that what
the Quran says? No, no, it does. The
Quran says it came confirming the Yeah,
it confirmed Allah confirmed the prophet
came. Allah confirmed the book. He said
in the past, but even in Muhammad's
time, they have to judge by the Torah,
right? Allah also says that they have
rewritten over the scripture. It doesn't
say that. It doesn't say that in the
Quran. You know, it doesn't it doesn't
say that they wrote over the scripture.
It says that you're misquing the Quran,
brother. Listen. It says it says it says
it says that unto those who write with
their own hand and then attribute it to
God. Okay? So, it doesn't say that they
rewrote over the scriptures, right?
They've attributed. So, they changed.
Very good. So, if I I got you. No. So if
I hold Hold on. If I write a if I write
a fake book, I'm answering you. I'm
answering. I'm answering. No. Not to the
scriptures. No. Not to the scriptures.
Okay. All right. Let me ask you. That's
what a Muslim. Okay. So if I know I know
I know you're a Muslim. You don't
believe the Quran. You don't believe the
Quran. Quran. I'm about to show you how.
Okay. If I write a fake book and I
attribute it to God to Allah, does that
mean that the Quran's been changed all
of a sudden? Say that again. If I wrote
a fake book myself, I wrote a book with
my own hands and then I attribute it to
Allah, does this mean that now the Quran
has suddenly been corrupted? No, we have
to see what the message very
good. Here's my point. The point is if
you if I write with my own hands
printing, listen to the point. If I
write with my own hands, that does not
mean that the Quran is corrupted. So
just like if they write with their own
hands, it does not mean the Gospel or
the Torah is corrupted. That's
silliness. Okay, so let's go back to
what we're talking about. word. This is
the direct word that Okay, so let's go
back to what we're talking about.
Someone could have wrote that. How do
you know? Someone could have wrote that.
Look, my brother. My brother. So, we we
look you're not listening anymore. I
think you went into bot mode, man. You
went in a bot. Come on, pay attention.
Anything has been taken out. If anything
has been added, if it does that, then we
say, you know what? There's things in
this book now has been added in. There's
things in this book now. I don't think
you want to say that taken out. We will
definitely say that. I don't think No,
you wouldn't. Therefore, cuz I can show
you some added words and verses.
Therefore, that will not be the original
Quran. All right. Cool. Thank you. All
right. Now, here's the question now.
Okay. The question going back, we saw in
Deuteronomy, it teaches that God is a
father. It teaches that Israel are are
his sons. Okay. The Israelites. That's
what it teaches in the gospel. I know
you don't believe that as a Muslim. This
is the whole point, brother. Trust me.
You're out of you're out of touch as a
Muslim. As a Muslim, you're out of touch
with the prophets. That's the point.
you're out of touch with the gospel. The
in Deuteronomy, it teaches that God is
our father. In Malachi, he says God is
our father who created us. In Psalm, it
says that he, the anointed one, is the
son of God who he puts on his holy hill
and mountain to rule. That's Psalm
chapter 2. So, in Psalm, in the Zabor,
in the Torah, and in the prophets, we
see that God is a father and the Messiah
is his son. We go to Matthew, Mark,
Luke, and John. What do we see? We see
God sent his only son into the world to
save the world. We see that Israel are
his children. We see that God adopts
believers as his children and that the
Messiah is his begotten son. Can I one
second? I'm going to wrap it up and I'll
let you respond. Okay. So, we see that
the Torah, the prophets, and Matthew,
Mark, Luke, and John are all consistent
on the message of God. But when we get
to the Quran, it says God is not our
father. He has no children. He doesn't
beget nor is he begotten. So it
contradicts alhamdulillah.
So the Quran contradicts. Yeah. So the
Quran contradicts what the prophets
taught. Can I talk now? That's the
point. Do you agree with that? Can I
talk now? Yeah. Just respond to this.
I'm going to respond to Okay. Yeah. Let
me let me give you quoted your
scripture. No. No. Hold on. Let me give
it to you specifically. Okay. I want you
to specifically respond to the point
that the prophets are consistent that
God is our father and the Messiah is his
son and the Matthew, Mark, Luke, and
John talked the same thing, but the
Quran is out of touch with that. Respond
to that. Not of mine is spoken from his
scriptures, old scriptures, meaning he's
trying to say he's speaking the word of
God. That's what he's referring to.
Well, the Quran says the word of God.
Okay. I now give you
that what does the one true God say
about this issue he's addressing right
now? He says go to the Bible. No, no,
no. It's okay. Robert, don't disturb me,
please. I listen to you carefully. You
You was You was disturbing me.
We go to chapter number nine people,
verse number 30. And this is what Allah
subhana wa ta'ala is saying. You're not
responding to the point. is saying the
Jews call us the son of Allah and the
Christian call Christ the son of Allah.
That is
a mouth in this day but imitate what the
unbelievers of the old used to say right
so let's look let's look into this
deeply okay in the time of Christ when
he came right the Roman body is there
the Roman authorities are there the
Roman government is there and then you
have the people the children of Israel
in their temple, right? What's going on
in Can you respond to the point, bro?
Brother, brother, brother, I'm sorry
Quran is a bit deep. I'm I'm sorry. It
requires patience, right, for it to get
in. But what can you do, my brother?
Right. I'm weeping. Please answer the
point. I' I've told you. Okay, if you
want me to answer the answer, do you
know what my point is? Listen, the Jews
call us. Wait, what? What was my point?
Just really quick. He wanted to say that
in the Old Testament, right, Moses or
the children of Israel, they claimed
that that God is our father, father,
right? So he went from his book. Yeah.
So he's trying to say Allah is is saying
that that this is all right. This is who
he is. In other words, this is what God
is, right? He's used the Old Testament,
right? I'm using my book. Wait, do you
know why? Do you remember why I did
that? Yeah. Yeah. But but but when we
when we see What was What was the reason
why I did that? Yeah. Yeah. Um I forgot
the reason. But one
second. I like it, bro. I like it. I
like it. I like it. I'm much older than
him. I got kids than him. I got
grandchildren. This man's just getting
started. That's right. Right. He's Soon
you're going to listen to him. Oh, my
baby kept me awake. I'm not. But I'm
doing it while I'm doing all of that.
So, just be patient with me. If you guys
have
sense, Islam is sense. Islam is heavy.
Can I remind you, Islam is waiting. I'm
giving you if Allah is saying the Jews
call us the son of Allah and the
Christians call Christ the son of Allah
that is the saying from their mouth in
that they imitate the unbelievers of the
old prophets were wrong that's all you
got to do to find out how did that end
up what is quoting right now so are the
prophets wrong
the prophets never said that we don't
believe that we don't believe that I got
So, so
so respect. All right. So, this is what
we got, guys. So, what we got is is that
Wait, wait. The prophets did not for you
from I would say for what' you say? I
have a message for you from All right.
After
this, so yeah, I'm in the middle of the
debate. So, what we have Sam? One
second. I'll stay here. I'll stay. I'll
stay. I'll stay. I'll stay. I'm here.
Surprise for you. Okay. I'll stay. All
right. So, so what we got here is that
at first he he forgot why I even
mentioned the point I mentioned. He
forgot why. I think I think I think I
did say it. No, you didn't. But let me
remind you. I'm trying to say in the Old
Testament. You forgot why we got here.
It's all right to say God is the father
of the children. But you forgot why. You
forgot why. The reason why I quoted the
prophets is because you said that we can
judge the last scripture or the newer
scriptures on the consistency of what
the prophets taught the Old Testament.
That's why I went to the Old Testament
to show you what the prophet said. And
that is wrong. Wait, hold on. Oh, that
it's wrong. But notice but notice here.
It's It's wrong. Wait, let me finish.
Let me finish. Now notice notice how he
then throws his own criteria under the
bus. I went by your standard and then as
soon as I showed you that by your
standard you're cooked. You like, oh,
you know what? Actually, my standard is
really the Quran. Yeah, it's hot. It's
hot, man. It's hot. So, this is where
we're at, bro. You don't know what the
angel is. You don't know who wrote it.
You don't know when it was written. And
you can't justify that it wasn't
Matthew, Mark, Luke, or John. Okay. So,
so, so at this point, all we know is
that Matthew, Mark, Luke, John wrote the
jail. We have no reason to think
otherwise. That's where we're at in this
conversation. I think he's cooking
himself. I really do think he's cooking
himself. He's cooking himself because
because you know what? Because what he's
saying,
[Applause]
stay in that pot.
Hey. Hey. Stay there. Hey, stop. Stop
trying to jump out. One second. Don't
try to jump out that butt. Keep doing
it. Don't y'all hate when y'all food
fight back? I hate when my food fights
back, man. Come on. Calm it down.
Comment down. Brother, do that again. I
want to add some spice to it.
Christianity
is carved up by the Romans
sprung out of
Jerusalem because they happen to be
there.
Meaning little bit of gas. Little bit
gas. Meaning if the Roman were not in
Jerusalem, I swear by Allah there would
be no Christianity. Oh, got it. Got it.
You like that? Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. He like
that. $5.99, bro. $5.99 for my I think
that's good. $5.99 for my good
conversation, man. Yeah, I think that's
Let's Let's
up. No. Yeah. Yeah. Is there Is there
another Muslim? Come to Islam.
Come to Islam. The last book. Because
when the other books corrupted, Christ
is Lord. When the other books corrupted,
Christ is king. It causes a book to come
down. And that's why this has come down.
Show me what Christ you know what's got
cooked. I hope when you see it, think
about it. If the Roman were not there,
there would be no Christianity. I wish
you gave me time to explain that. You
would have enjoyed it cuz it's full of
sense. Maybe next time. Maybe next time.
For sure. But this was awesome. Thank
you for talking to me. Y know. All
right. Next next take your crosses off.
It's God. It's God. is God.
[Music]